Transcriber: Alara Akgün
Gözden geçirme: İlker ÖZBAŞ
Şimdiki zamanın çok öncelerinde bir yerde,
Kendisi de romatoid artrit hastası
olan Elif Hanım, sanki birazdan
söyleyeceklerinden utanır gibi
usulca geldi yanıma.
Ve dedi ki, “Hocam bana bir yol göster.
Ben ölmek istiyorum.”
Şimdiye kadar okuduğum hiçbir kitapta bu
zamana kadar romatoid artritin anlatıldığı
makalelerde, yazılarda, kitaplarda
hiç rastlamayacağımız bu cümle;
bana hastayı, hastalığı ve nihayetinde
hekimliğimi anlamam için çok önemli bir
rol üstlendi.
Hani var ya Nietzsche’nin daha yüzyıllarca
yaşayacak o cümlesi, “Öldürmeyen
acı güçlendirir.”
Elif, bunun tam tersine acılardan
güç kazanmak yerine
ne yazık ki ölmeyi tercih ediyordu.
Songül vardı.
Bir akşam üzeri vizitte, “Yarın bebeğini
kucağına alacaksın.” diyerek
vedalaştığımız Songül, ne yazık ki o gece
lupus hastalığının bir tuzağıyla,
bebeğiyle vedalaşmak zorunda kaldı.
Arzuyu çok iyi hatırlıyorum.
Lupus tanısını koyduğum gün, güneş
görmemen gerekir dediğimde
arabasının bütün camlarını
simsiyah yapmıştı.
O Arzu,
sosyal toplumun baskısıyla evliliğini
sürdürmenin yolunu çocuk sahibi olmak
olduğunu zannetti.
Ama hamileliğinin devamında,
son haftasına geldiğinde
hem bebeği hem kendisi
hayatını kaybetmişti.
Narin'i çok iyi hatırlıyorum.
Karşılaştığım gün, okula gidemediği
için geldiğini söylemişti.
Ne zamandan beri dediğimde, “Ben
çocukluğumdan beri” diyordu.
Çocukluğundan bu yana yazı yazmak, kalem
tutmak,
okula gitmek ile ilgili sorunları vardı.
Çocukluğunda isminin başına
bir sıfat eklenmişti.
Topal.
Battaniyeyi kaldıramayacak kadar ismi
gibi narin bir bedeni vardı
ve bir keresinde, “Yemek yemiyorum,
su içmiyorum
çünkü yersem, içersem açıkça lavaboya
gitmem gerekiyor.” diyordu.
Düşünebilir misiniz lütfen?
Bunu bir düşünün.
Açlığı tercih ediyor, susuzluğu tercih
ediyor çünkü lavaboya gidecek hali yok.
Onu yürütecek dizleri yok.
Merhaba, ben Doktor Süleyman Özbek.
Önünde 17 ve Haziran
yazan yılların birinde,
muhtemelen evde ebe yardımıyla
dünyaya geldim. Mersin’de.
Mahallemin ilkokuluna, mahallemin
ortaokuluna gittim; ama lise için
trene binmem gerekiyordu.
Benim üniversiteye girdiğim yıl Türkiye’de
13 tıp fakültesi vardı.
Sanırım şimdi 120 civarında
tıp fakültesi var.
Hepiniz biliyorsunuz, tıp fakültesinde
öğrenim 6 yıldır;
ama hekim olarak baktığınızda
bir ömür boyu eğitim vardır.
Her Öğretmenler Günü’nde
bir cümle paylaşırım.
“Öğrenmek, sonsuza yolculuktur.
Öğretmek, sonsuzda var olmak.
Ben çok şanslıyım.
Benim yolum, yolculuğum sonsuza,
sonsuzda var olmaya.
“Genç bir psikoterapi öğrencisi olarak
yolumu bulmaya çalışırken
okuduğum en yararlı kitap,
Karen Horney’nin Nevrozlar ve
İnsan Gelişimi adlı kitabıydı.” diyor
Irvin Yalom, Bağışlanan Terapi
isimli kitabında.
Bu arada ben birçok reçeteme,
hastalarımla karşılaştığımda
Irvin Yalom’un adını yazarım.
“Nesi varsa alın” derim.
Sonra telefon açarlar, “Hocam, Nesi Varsa
diye bir kitabı yokmuş.” derler.
Gerçekten tavsiye ederim.
Muhteşem.
Devam ediyor Irvin Yalom ve kitaptaki en
yararlı tek kavram
Karen Horney’e göre, insanların içinde
kendini geliştirmeye yönelik
doğal bir eğilimin olduğuna inanıyordu.
Karen Horney; eğer engeller kaldırılırsa
bireyin, tıpkı meşe ağacında gelişen
palamut gibi olgun ve kendini
gerçekleştirmiş olacağına inanıyordu.
Tıpkı meşe ağacında gelişen
palamut gibi olgun.
Ne kadar özgürleştirici ve
aydınlatıcı bir imge.
Devam ediyor Irvin Yolum, “Çalışmalarımda
bana bambaşka bir bakış açısı getirdi ve
psikoterapi alanında bana
bir çığır açtı.” diyor.
Benim görevim, hastanın yolunu tıkayan
engelleri bulup ortadan kaldırmaktı.
Gerisi hastanın içinde bulunan, hepimizde
bulunan gelişme arzusu, merak, irade,
hayat coşkusu, ilgi, sadakat ya da bizi
tamamen insan yapan özellikler konusunda
hastayı teşvik etmek zorunda değildim.
Hayır, benim yapmam gereken şey engelleri
bulup ortadan kaldırmaktı.
Psikoterapi alanı için yazılmış bu
yazıyı,  bu cümleleri noktasına virgülüne
dokunmadan romatoloji için de
romatologlar için de söyleyebilirim.
Ben bir romatoloji uzmanı olarak
benim de yolum hastanın yolunu
tıkayan engelleri kaldırmaktı.
Nedir romatoloji derseniz. Romatoloji,
bağışıklık sistemi hastalıklarının
araştırıldığı, teşhis edildiği,
tedavilerinin sürdürüldüğü
bir bilim alanıdır.
Bağışıklık sistemi; bir bedenin koruyucu
sistemi, güvenlik sistemi, bir ülkenin
ordusu gibi her yerde. Deride, akciğerde,
kalpte, beyinde, böbrekte
eklemlerde, bağırsaklarda. Dolayısıyla
eğer bize, bana, romatolojiye
bir bağışıklık sistemi
problemiyle bir hasta geldiyse
bir organın değil, bütün bir bedenin
hastalığından söz ederiz.
Bu açıdan baktığımızda bu hastalıklar
sinsi hastalıklardır. Kendi, gerçek, öz
karakteristik belirtilerini
vermediği sürece tanınmaları çok geçtir.
Kimi hastalıkların on yıl sonra teşhis
edildiğine hepimiz şahit oluyoruz.
Hasta, hekime ağrı nedeniyle gelir ama bu
ağrıyı kitabi olarak baktığınız zaman
arkadaşlar sözlüğe.
“Rahatsız edici bir duygu”, “Hoş olmayan
bir duygu” diye tarif eder.
Kitapta öyle yazar, cümleler öyledir,
satırlar öyledir. Ama bu ağrıyı yaşayan
insanın bir
tanesinin sözünü çok iyi hatırlıyorum.
“Hocam kaç defa alnıma silah
dayadım.” demişti.
Bir soru soracağım: Dayanılması
en kolay ağrı hangisidir?
Sessizlik değil. Baş ağrısı, o da değil.
O benim ağrım.
Arkadaşlar, dayanılması en kolay
ağrı, başkasının ağrısıdır.
Bu hastalar bize romatoloji hastaları
hep romatizmam var diye.
Duyarsın hep, “Romatizmam, romatizmam.”
Burada aslında romatoloji alanında,
150 200 civarında hastalık vardır.
Ne yazık ki hepsine romatizma deniliyor.
Hepsinin ayrı, farklı, birbirine benzer
ama birbirinden çok farklı özelikleri
nedeniyle isimlendirilmişler.
Kimi hasta bize kalbinin çevresinde
su toplanmış olarak gelir.
Perikardit.
Kimi hasta, akciğerinde bir emboli vardır.
Kimisi pnömoni vardır, kimisinin
böbrek tutulumu vardır.
Ne yazık ki bazı hastalıklarda yüzde 80-
85. Bu hastalıklar böyle baktığımız zaman
hem yaşam kalitesini yerlerde süründürür,
çok azaltır hem de
yaşam süresini kısaltır.
Ağızda aft.
Bunu konuşurken hastalarımla garipserler.
Sokağa çıkıp anket yapsak. Ben ders
anlatırken sınıfta öğrencilere soruyorum.
Yüzde 8-10 kişi evet diyor.
Herkesin bir bahanesi var ama aft
romatoloji da çok önemli bir belirtidir.
Mesela lupus.
Lupus, Arzu’nun hastalığıydı.
Hamileliğin son haftasında,
burada değildim, görmedim ama takip
eden arkadaşlarım vardı .
Bebeği karnında parçalanmıştı.
Kendisinin de karaciğeri parçalanmıştı
son haftalarda.
Arzu gerçekten arkadaşlar
tamamen evliliğinin sürdürülebilmesi için
onun, bunun, şunun kaynanasının
“Ne zaman doğum olacak, ne zaman?”
diye diye sonunda istenmediği bir halde,
hazır olmadığı halde hamileliği seçmişti.
Lupus, on hastada baktığımız zaman
dokuzunda kadın, biri erkektir.
Öyle baktığımız zaman, lupus örneğinden
de söyleyebilirim.
Romatoloji hastalıkları cinsel ayrımcılık
yapıyor ve ne yazık ki birçoğu
erkeklerde görülen birkaç tane
ağırlıklı hastalık var
ama bir çoğu kadınlar için negatif
ayrımcılık yapıyor.
Benim hekimliğim boyunca masamda kazınmış,
demirlemiş bir cümle var.
Eklemi ağrıyan her genç kadında
lupus ekarte edilmelidir.
Bu, bütün hekim arkadaşlarım için
kullandığımız, çalıştığımız bir cümle
Behçet var.
Dünya literatüründe Türk hekimin adıyla
geçmiş bir hastalık. Romatoid artrit var.
Romatoid artritin toplumda dünya genelinde
görülme sıklığı yüzde 1 olur, yüzde 1.
Baktığınızda sanki nadir, az gibi görünür.
Ama bir ailede Elif'i düşünün.
Narin'i düşünün.
Bir ailede bir romatoid artrit varsa o bir
kişinin hastalığı değildir arkadaşlar.
O ailedeki bütün insanlar
o hastalıktan etkilenir.
Uyanacak sabah. Bir saat, iki saat, belki
öğlene kadar çeşmeyi açamayacak,
musluğu çeviremeyecek,
elbisesini giyemeyecek.
Anne ise çocuğunun kahvaltısını
hazırlayamayacak, okuluna gönderemeyecek.
Erkeklerde de görülür.
Kadınlarda daha fazla görülür.
Bir hastamın sözüyle romatoid artriti
simgeleyeyim isterseniz.
Çoğu hasta bize bu şekilde gelir,
geç tanı kondukları
ve etkili tedavi alamadıkları için.
Bugün tedaviler konusunda da tanı
konusunda da romatoloji çok iyi yerde.
Onu söylemek zorundayım ve bu sevindirici
bir şey tabii ki.
Ben 91 yılından beri romatolojideyim.
30′uncu yılındayım. Çok keyifle,
bu konuşmayı da
keyifle yapıyorum, zevkle yapıyorum.
Romatoid artrit hastalarda şu cümleye
başlarını salarlar arkadaşlar hastalar.
Yangın çıksa evden çıkamayacak
durumda insanlar var romatoid artrit olup.
Lütfen düşünün.
Yangın çıksa evden çıkamayacak durumda.
Yaşam kalitesi, yaşam süresi bunlardan
bahsetmiştim, bir de Ankilozan Spondilit
isimli bir hastalık var.
Bütün dünyaya baktığımızda 5 ile 10 yıl
arasında hastalık tanısı gecikir.
Oysa o kadar kolaydır ki arkadaşlar
iki satır söyleyeceğim.
Sabahları yataktan kalktığında belinde
ağrı ve tutulma ile uyanan ve hareketle
ağrısı, tutulması geçen bir hasta.
Bu kadar kolay, bu kadar ama ne yazık ki
iki satırda anlatabileceğim, özetleyeceğim
hastalığın bugün halen bugünkü pratiğimde
dahi, 30′uncu yılımdayım,
halen çok geç geliyorlar hastalar.
Neden çok geçten bu kadar
çok bahsediyorum
çünkü bu süreçte eğer ne kadar erken tanı
koyar ve etkili tedavi verirsen
o kadar başarılı oluyor tedaviler.
Özetle, bu kadar hastalık var ama bunların
sonunda hepsini bir romatizma çuvalının
içine atıyoruz.
Romatoloji böyle, romatolog nedir
diye de kısaca bahsedeyim.
İç hastalıkları ihtisası yaparız. Beş yıl
kadar sürer, üzerine üç ya da dört yıl
kadar sürecek romatoloji ihtisası yaparız.
Aralarda tıp fakültesi bitiriminde,
iç hastalıkları ve romatoloji bitiriminde
ikişer yıl mecburi hizmetlerimiz var.
Erkekse askerlik yapacak, kadın haliyle
bu süreç içerisinde hamilelikleri ve
anneliğe olabilecek.
Nereden baksanız yaklaşık böyle 40 yaşına
gelmiş bir insan oluyor karşınızda.
Ve “Yaşasın romatolog oldun.” diyerek
sırtı sıvazlanıyor.
Bu durum, umutsuzluğa düşürmesin
çünkü çok zor elde ediyoruz tamam.
Bu bir şeyi ama hayatta sahip
olduğunuz şeylere bakın lütfen.
Ne kadar çok emek, ne kadar çok çaba sarf
ettiyseniz, elinizde tuttuğunuz şey
tırnak içerisinde o kadar kıymetlidir,
o kadar değerlidir.
Benim için romatoloji bir aşk.
Altı üstü romatoloji.
Altı üstü aşk.
Onun sayesinde doktor değil, hekim oldum.
Onun sayesinde çok iyi insanlar tanıdım,
biriktirdim.
Onun sayesinde ağrıyla yaşamına son
vermek isteyen bir hastayla karşılaştım.
Sayfayı çevirdim.
Gülen bir yüz, sıcacık bir el gördüm.
Dolayısıyla az önceki söylediğim gibi
umutsuz olmaya hakkımız yok.
Umut, güzel bir şeydir. Bir şeyden, bir
fikirden, bir insandan umut etmektir.
En güçlü bağ hayata, bağlılıktır umut.
Bir şeye, bir fikre, bir insana. Ağrıyı
yaşamını kısıtlayacak derecede kötü
şartlarda yaşayan bir insan karşısında
hekim olarak hiçbirimizin umutsuz olmaya
hakkı yok.
Elbette hastaların ve hastalıkların
tedavisinde, tanınmasında birkaç tane de
öneriyle konuşmamı bitireceğim.
Hep erken tanı diyoruz.
Erken tanı ve erken tedavi. Ne kadar erken
olursa. Üç ay sonra.
Ne kadar erken olursa. Eskiden 90′lı
yıllarda, 2 yıl gibi bir rakama
erken deniyordu. Bugün, yarın
tanıyabilsem ne kadar güzel derim.
Yarın tanıyabilmek için yöntemlerimiz var.
Ama ifade çok önemli, hasta ifadesi.
Dinlemek.
Ve laboratuvarımız da
tabii ki bugün çok gelişti.
Ama bu gelişmeler bir yere yaradı,
bir yerden de kaynaklandı.
Tedavide çok büyük gelişmeler oldu.
Çalışma hayatımda, bütün öğrencilik
yıllarımızda bize öğretilen bir şey var.
Empati.
Ama bu empati eksiksiz, doğru
ama dozunda olmalı.
Anlamaktan öte bir de sahiplenmeyiz.
Benim hayatım böyleydi.
Reçete yazdıktan sonra hastaya reçeteyi
uzatırken iki şey söylerim.
Birisi sizin evinizde, sofranızda
benim tabağım var.
Bana o ağrıyla gelen insanın sofrasında
ben yemek yiyemem çünkü. Bir.
İkincisi, hasta beni
her an arayabilmeli.
Bütün hastalarımda telefon vardır ve
bugüne kadar ben hiçbir hastamın beni
gereksiz aradığını düşünmem,
görmedim hiç.
İkinci şey, hastaların yaraları
ve bunu da anlamalıyız.
Burada da destek olmalıyız.
Bunu vazgeçemeyen bu, bu
durumu düşünemeyiz.
Böbreği tutulmuştur, beyni tutulmuştur,
konuşamıyordur,
akciğerinde sorun vardır
ama dinlemeli ve anlamalıyız.
Yine reçeteyi yazarken, verirken
ikinci bir cümlem daha var.
“Bana ne kadar iyi olacağım diye
sorar mısın?” diyorum.
“Ne kadar?” diyor. “Hayır, uzun sor.”
diyorum.
“Ne kadar iyi olacağım?”
Bunun bence bir tek cevabı var.
İstediğin kadar.
Bu da önemli şartlardan
bir tanesi tedavide.
Çünkü bu karşılıklı
bir çabayı gerektiriyor.
Hastanın iyi olma isteği
bizim için çok önemli.
Ha diyeceksiniz ki, “İyi olmayı
istemeyen hasta olur mu?”
Pratiğimizde var, görüyoruz.
Karşılıklı saygı, sevgi, güven olmazsa
olmaz. Bütün ilişkilerimizde elbette.
Ama hekimlikte de mutlaka.
Erken tanı için bilgiye ihtiyacımız var.
Bizim bilgiye ihtiyacımız var. Toplumun
bilgiye ihtiyacı var ama doğru bilgiye.
İnternette okuduğumuz her bilginin
yüzde yüz doğru olmayacağını bilmeliyiz.
Ben birçok hastamla karşılaştığımda,
romatoid artrit için özellikle.
“Sigara içiyor musun?” diye sormuyorum.
“Sigarayı ne zaman bırakacaksın?”
dediğimde çok etkileyici bir cümle.
Hasta bana hiç daha sigarayı
söylemiyor dahi.
Çünkü romatoid artritin bilinen
en önemli çevresel faktörü,
neden olarak sigara.
Hem neden hem de tedaviyi
engelleyen bir faktör.
Karşılıklı sevgi, güven ve
saygıya tekrar gelirsem.
İnsan, karşısındakini kendisinde
olanı verir.
Kendinde olmayanı veremez.
“Bana bir elma verir misin?” diyeceğim.
“Yok ki vereyim.” diyeceksiniz.
Dolayısıyla kendisine, kendine sevgi .
Kendisine, kendine güven.
Kendisine, kendine saygı olduğunda
verecektir hasta. İnsan.
Buradaki verme, cebinizdeki herhangi bir
şeyi vermekten daha farklı arkadaşlar.
Karşınızdaki kişiye sevgi verdikçe, saygı
verdikçe, güven verdikçe
güveniniz çoğalır, saygınız çoğalır,
sevginiz çoğalır.
İnsanlar aynaya bakarlar.
Duvarda asılı olan aynaya. Hepimiz, herkes
güzel bir şey görmek için bakarlar.
Aslında insanlar, insana da aynaya
baktığı gibi bakarlar.
Baktıkları insanda kendilerini
güzel görmek için.
Dolayısıyla genel bir söz ama
baktığınızda sizi kendinize güzel
gösteren insanlar biriktirin.
Hekimlere sözüm: Hastalarınızı dinleyin,
size öğretmelerine izin verin.
Dinleyenlere sözüm: Bilgiye ulaşmak için,
bilgeliğe ulaşmak için
hayatınız boyunca
öğrenci kalmaya devam edin.
Çok teşekkür ederim.